[MUSIC]
A lot of the communication that's going on
with Twitter is
the simple dissemination of information.
If a firm has some news they want to get
out to the markets,
they use a tweet to tweet the information
and a link to it.
And then the question is, does this have
an effect?
Does this improve the information
environment of the firm?
[MUSIC]
We look at these firms, and
we examine when they tweet versus when
they don't tweet, and we find that
when they choose to tweet an event, that
the market liquidity's actually improved.
We see bid ask spreads narrow, and we see
the depths widen.
And more importantly, we see this effect
as being stronger for
those firms that you would call less
visible, those that might have
trouble getting attention from the
traditional media outlets.
So it'd be firms that are smaller, firms
that have fewer shareholders,
firms that have fewer institutions looking
at them.
These firms are the ones that have more
trouble getting their message out.
And Twitter is a channel that they can use
to
more broadly disseminate their
information.
[MUSIC]
My first advice would be to definitely
take it seriously.
A lot of these new technologies, it's easy
to dismiss because it's not the way that
you've done things in the past, and it's
not the, the traditional,
normal way of communicating with
investors, but as we show in our study,
Twitter can be extremely helpful for firms
that are using it.
Especially if they can't get attention
from the traditional media outlets.
This is a new channel, this is a new way
of communicating.
And it does impact the firm's information
environment.
It helps their market liquidity.
S, my advise would be to look at Twitter
or look at Facebook.
Or look at these different technologies
and see what's right for your firm.
Think about what your goals are and what
you want to accomplish.
And work, and
think about how these tools might help you
better communicate with your investors.
[MUSIC]
The way that firms are communicating with
investors, it's changing.
Whether firms want it to or not, the
advent of new technology coming in and
different venues for them to interact
with.
It's changing investors' expectations, and
it's changing the possibilities for firms.
So the exciting thing is that firms, they
can choose to embrace this.
And they can start to see some real
benefits coming from it.
[MUSIC]